hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the international giveaway of
the google edition htc one or the
samsung galaxy s4 this one is pretty
simple to get in on it's entirely
youtube based here so it's very simple
the choice you have here is the google
edition htc one or the google edition
galaxy s4 and all you have to do to get
entered is be a subscriber of the
youtube channel and leave a comment down
below with one of those two names of the
devices again those are the only two
choices but you should probably choose
wisely but that's not all that is not
even close to all this wouldn't be
complete without some sort of way to get
some extra entries or an extra way to
win and that's exactly what we've done
here have paired up with lou from unbox
therapy our favorite canadian you've
probably heard of him he does some
awesome videos he has a video just like
this on his channel so there's an
annotation for that there will also be a
link in the description below that like
button where you can check it out and
you also have the ability to comment on
his video after subscribing to get in on
this giveaway twice so that'll double
your chances and one comment on each of
these videos will count as an entry you
can leave a different comment on each
video if you want but you're probably
going to want to double your chances to
win that one device that you really want
so pick carefully choose wisely because
you can either choose one on one video
and the other on the other video where
you can double your chances of winning
one of these great the very interesting
smartphones on either of these giveaway
videos either way the winners will be
selected in one week so as far as
winners are concerned we'll be
announcing that on july 25th on twitter
so that's a week from today and these
will be shipped anywhere in the world so
you're definitely going to want to stay
tuned to the twitter the twitter links
will be in the description below and
that's we're going to be able to stay
tuned and find out if you won your pick
and you also get updates on the details
of the giveaway but for the sake of
clarity all of your helpful rules links
and information will be in the
description below that like button so
you can check out everything there all
your youtube video links your channel
subscribe links and your twitter links
and your dates will all be in the
description so that's where you'll be
able to find everything and make sure
you properly get entered and properly
double your chances to win again check
out all of unbox therapy videos
subscribe to his channel and make sure
you stay tuned here for the next mkbhd
video best of luck and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video peace
you